all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with the x-men we're getting back into
the current stuff uh we will go back and
cover like the actual volumes of the
things that happened at the beginning of
house and powers of x
the things we didn't really get a chance
to cover but this one is really more of
a very very current story and this deals
with
essentially uh x-23 the all-new all
different wolverine laura kenny whatever
you want to call her
sink and darwin who were sent into the
vault now this is one of those instances
when i talk about how
jonathan hickman will do something and
then totally ignore it for like a year
and then circle back to it again right
this there was a lot of things that
happened between when this took place
when they were sent
into the vault and what's going on now
it's just the nature of jonathan hickman
writing if you don't have the patience
for it
he'll lose you very very fast and so one
of the things that happened is we had
what were called the children of the
vault now a little bit of a refresher
here the children of the vault are
really just kind of the end result of
the efforts of bella pagan and of course
they debuted back
in x-men vol 2 issue 188 in 2006. the
whole idea behind the children of the
vault is they
are a result of what's called genetic
drift or temporal acceleration and all
this really means
is that they're not quite human but
they're not quite mutant they're one of
these things where they're basically
considered post-humans or evolved humans
so what if humans had advanced to the
point where they started developing
powers but the important thing here
is that these guys are basically humans
more or less who exist
inside this vault where time passes
differently it actually accelerates at a
much much faster pace
but in terms of your physical response
to time it largely remains the same and
we'll learn more about that as we as we
kind of get into this
but the children of the vault or at
least the the efforts of bella pagan
actually ended up finding success in
south america and that basically led to
the formation of what we know as the
children of the vault now
and so because the vault is one of these
things where no one really knows
anything about it
the mission of x-23 and sync and darwin
is to go in and investigate now the
reason why these three were chosen
is because one i mean laura kenny she
was created to be an assassin
if you're gonna have anybody go in there
and be the one that knows how to fight
it's gonna be her darwin as a lot of you
guys know is an omega level mutant whose
body has the ability to adapt to
basically any environment so if they
came down here and the environment was
such that like it was
toxic to basically everybody then darwin
would have the ability to
alter his physical form so he could
survive the experience
and sync has the ability to basically
copy the powers of anybody he's in the
vicinity of so long as they're close
enough and so he'd be able to basically
copy the powers of darwin and then in
turn
operate in this space and so that's how
all these things kind of work together
now there have been differences with
sync that's one of the things i want to
talk about for a second
over the years the nature of his power
has waxed and waned there's been
instances where all he has to do is just
be standing close enough to a person and
he can copy their powers
there have been other instances where he
has to be physically touching them to
copy their powers so
it's really changed and the extent of
the powers he can duplicate has never
been fully revealed
largely it's just been you know you're
kind of regular average mutants people
who can fly
people who can heal themselves but we've
never really seen him copy the powers of
someone who can alter reality right like
matthew malloy or somebody like that
mostly because you know he was gone and
out of the picture by the time matthew
malloy was around but i imagine during
jonathan hickman's run he's going to
accelerate that and we're actually going
to see
sync pull off some pretty ridiculous
things but what they end up doing is
just kind of getting through here
and doing a bit of investigation and
it's kind of a funny thing because
as they start off here laura kinney i
wouldn't say has a disdain for sync but
it's laura kinney being laura kinney
right in the sense that she's kind of
she pops her claws when he's staring at
her and she's like what are you looking
at you know like that kind of a thing
and so ultimately it's one of those like
we have a mission to to engage in here
now one of the things that happens is
that as this is taking place
that one of the individuals here is
basically being resurrected or being
brought back
by the sentience of the city right its
machine or its mind whatever it is that
you want to call it but the way this
works is that when it comes to the
children of the vault whenever one of
them is killed
basically they bring all the information
back so it's very similar to what krakow
does it's almost identical in fact to
what kakoa does and the idea is that for
the city itself
essentially the desire is to evolve its
people to the point that it can
essentially conquer the world that's the
whole goal is they believe that only one
race can dominate the earth
and that they have to be the ones to do
it and while humanity in and of itself
is not really a credible threat and it's
one of the things that the city says
right like i mean people are people and
like what's the worst humanity has
a nuclear bomb okay whatever who cares
the important thing
is humans are a major credible threat
now one of the things that i do want to
point out here is that for this young
girl she's one of the victims of orcis
if you guys remember during house and
powers of x she was taken by orcas kind
of experimented on that kind of a thing
and then ultimately ended up dying so
all the information of what humanity is
fully capable of in this moment
is downloaded into her database and
that's the important thing is because
for a group that almost never really
goes out into the world it's the only
real way for them to be aware of what
the world is capable of and that's the
nature of the children of the vault they
go out into the world every so often
they see what humanity is capable of
they might start a fight and just see
what you know see how well they they've
evolved in terms of powers or
capabilities
and then if they lose they die they come
back and the city evolves them to the
next stage so they can basically
because they can adapt or they can cope
with whatever it was that killed them
the first time
and so that's one of the things that
happens here is that because the anomaly
of
x-23 and sync and darwin is detected by
the city
they're sent out into the city in order
to confront them now the reality is this
is one part just self-preservation right
like there is a foreign body in the city
we have to destroy it in case they want
to do us harm but the other part of this
is experimentation
let's see how well you fare against
these guys and if they prove to be too
powerful for you
then we'll evolve you to the next level
so you can basically take them out and
then they'll just be kind of a sample
size and then we'll send you out again
and again and again and again and again
until everybody that goes against you
perishes at your hands then we'll know
you're ready and so when this whole
conflict kicks off you've got x-23 you
got darwin you got sync who basically
jump in
and they immediately start taking out
all these individuals right literally
just annihilating them all the way to
the point
that the girl is the only one left and
then ultimately she self detonates
but again the information that all these
guys have in terms of the experience
facing off against x23 the capability
she has
the knowledge of her healing factor
after seeing her sustain injuries in
terms of how
fast she heals from injuries is
basically being kept here and so when
they're brought back
all that information is redownloaded
into the machine so that they can be
evolved and upgraded to sustain this
whole conflict again and that's one of
the things that goes on
is because time passes differently the
kind of statement that's given to us
here
is that something like 50 years have
basically passed
since the beginning of all this right
that's just how much time has passed
in this relatively short period of time
they've been here following that it's
just kind of investigating the city and
taking
pot shots it's them coming to the
realization the city has the capability
of healing itself right basically fixing
itself and evolving itself to be able to
withstand
even more injury should anything come
along right so this explosion this girl
let off with the city repairing itself
it won't endure that same process again
they follow through and they kind of go
through what are basically these growth
tanks where the machine is growing all
these various individuals and then in
turn
seeing what happens it's just kind of
this this interesting process the entire
place
is completely and totally self-contained
and so that's when a kind of explanation
is given
where basically we learn that with the
city itself the power
is memory and so one of the things they
reference here is a child named diamante
who is kind of a living repository of
vault history and that's where they
learn the entire history of the vault in
its entirety
and one of the things that's told to us
here is that years ago the x-men had
encountered the children of the vault
they were considered the first
generation of children it follows up and
it says and from their defeat at the
hands of mutandum
earth's first post-humans learned that
they too had to evolve
and the second generation of children
were produced and let loose on the world
these children were captured dissected
and repurposed by orcis
as potential weapons for the creation of
a nation-state and so again the second
generation of
of children of the vault those are the
ones who were captured by orcas and
those are the ones that were going to be
used by orcas against the mutant
population
of course they were all pretty much
defeated and destroyed and so following
that it says
seraphina escaped and when the city
learned their fate it was decided that
yet another evolutionary leap was needed
this was to be the third and final
generation of children before they were
released from the vault to claim the
earth as their own
with this we had learned what we needed
and it was time to return
home the biggest thing about this is
that now they've been there for 100
years but notice this despite having
been here for so incredibly long
they've still stayed relatively young
now a lot of this is because of how time
impacts the living
body versus how it impacts in the normal
world but two they're just feeding off
each other's powers that laura kitty has
a healing factor which keeps her from
aging at a normal rate that sync has the
ability to copy her power and darwin's
body is designed to adapt so that's why
they were able to kind of survive
all this ultimately they ended up coming
face to face with the city only to find
out that there was a trap that had been
set and they've been laying in weight
for decades waiting on these guys to
show up because they knew they would
eventually it's one of these things
where when the children of the vault had
encountered laura
and darwin and sync and it all been
destroyed that they came to the
realization
they're still out there we haven't
caught them yet but they're still there
so then we'll just be patient we'll just
wait we'll bide our time
eventually they will have to come to us
because their entire mission for being
here is rooted in gaining information
and this is the best place to do it
and that's what kind of goes nuts is
ultimately laura is taken and darwin's
taken
and then sync is taken and they're all
basically kind of held as prisoners in
different forms or fashion
now sync of course given his experience
all the things he's learned
in the time that he was in this city one
of the things that had happened
is a romance that formed between him and
laura kinney they fell in love
and so ultimately sync actually ends up
fashioning a weapon of sorts that allows
him to escape and then ultimately tracks
down the location of laura kinney and
then helps her escape
and they kind of go on the run now this
is one of those moments when what it is
that jonathan hickman's doing is
exceedingly important
and the reason why is because they
ultimately end up locating darwin
but when they do darwin's destroyed he's
wiped out in the process
now there's a couple different reasons
why this was done the first is because
the city was analyzing darwin and
learning to understand his powers
and two once darwin was destroyed his
body's ability or his mutant powers
ability to adapt
to any situation was instilled in all
the various clones that exist in the
city
so that when they're born or they come
to maturity whatever it is you want to
call it they will have the ability to
adapt to virtually any circumstance in a
single generation
is basically the birth of an entire
godly post-human race
it's nuts right it's one of the crazy
things and so ultimately because of this
realization understanding what's going
on
laura in sync and the only thing they
can really hope to do is find a way to
make contact with professor x so they
can warn him of what's going on inside
this fault
and what the people in this vault are
capable of doing now for the most part
once they run through a kind of force
field or a kind of energy gate
that they they survive right because
laura kenny has the ability to heal
herself and
sink is feeding off her her mutant power
but the thing is they kind of have to
say goodbye to each other and while it's
not necessarily as drawn out as it could
have possibly been
and it really didn't need to be the fact
that they spent a hundred years together
and ultimately have to walk away is
crushing not so much because of the fact
that they'll never
see each other again but because this
100 year long relationship will
basically be lost
and that's kind of the crazy thing is
because when this whole thing pops off
laura tells him like you saved me
so now let me save you right i can stay
here i can fight i can deal with them
you know i can i can cope with these
guys right here mutant power is
kind of gone essentially it's basically
fading fast the city's ability to kind
of kind of offer defense mechanism
sync ultimately makes it out of the
vault and as soon as he does he
basically hollers at xavier xavier reads
his mind
downloads the information and then sinks
killed by the children of the vault and
that's one of the things they say here
right they say like you know we can hear
you
just fine and they basically say now
before you die i want you to hear me
we are going to wipe your kind from the
face of this planet we're basically
the future here and so in essence for
those of you guys who read house and
powers of x
and we were talking about post-humans
who basically rose to power
and we didn't really know exactly how
that had happened it starts here right
this is the nature of jonathan hickman
that everything he's doing here will
build into house and powers of x in a
lot of ways with that story he gave us
the conclusion
and now he's building up to show us how
we get to that point that's one of the
things that we covered that we talked
about in that story and that's what's
playing out here now because sync made
it out of the vault all the information
and everything his whole experiences are
all still kind of maintained and for
laura kinney that's not the case
she's reborn and she's essentially
brought back but the relationship and
the memory of the relationship that she
had with sync
is non-existent the birthing process for
her basically cuts off her knowledge to
before she went into the vault and so
again like sync kind of looks back at
her and sees this whole process and says
hey like you know we were in love once
looking at her the psycho repeats itself
right she pops her claws what are you
looking at
and that's it but there is potential
there and so basically is hickman kind
of establishing hey
like sync is kind of digging laura
kinney and like they'll probably end up
getting together but it's one of these
cool things man it's stuff like this
that i love with jonathan hickman where
you just kind of get these small little
stories
these little tidbits i mean this is like
a two issue story it's pretty short but
it's cool because this will build into
something
huge it's gonna be very very significant
later on down the line but with that
being said guys
thank you for watching i love you guys
to death and i will catch you all later
peace